the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and Welcome to our summer
chess classes it's so wonderful to be
with you yes yesterday we had a lot of
fun we're going to conspire to have more
fun right absolutely yes that's the plan
hello everyone and Welcome to our show I
really we had a lot of fun yesterday
we're going to have a lot of fun
throughout let's take a look at our
standings for our two events starting
with group a pagan please sendings are
pranavis leading the tournaments with
one point of the rest of the group
almost made a draw and ABI money loss
against burnout that's the situation for
you just one winner and the standings in
Group B I think we had three winner
sections yeah Group B was a month full
yesterday Brendan Jacobson
Akshay Chandra won their games again
against Alexander Linderman Justin wine
look at the Salvage and the rest of the
games ended in a draw absolutely and
tell as we see all the at the chase
Hotel here in Central West End of St
Louis tell us about the format for the
two tournaments so former basketball
tournaments both of them 10 player round
robin
the minutes for the first 40 meals and
30 minutes for the rest of the game with
30 seconds increment throughout the game
schedule is pretty straightforward yes
absolutely we have games every day till
August 10th No Rest days yes or for you
exactly and we are on the air each and
every day at 4 P.M so the games have
been well underway let's jump into the
pairings tell us about the group a
hearings group a pairings look great
today and our key matchup is Darius
Schwarz against pranav and pranav was in
our studio yesterday he's a bright
talented 16 year old chess player and
Darius is already established during
Grandmaster very strong and it's a very
exciting game absolutely 16 year old and
very very mature let's just jump into
that game for a moment and again these
players have been underway for some time
we come in yeah
screen and what we have after this last
move and I think that this is really
interesting yesterday we had that game
of Brandon and Lenderman where it was
two Bishops versus two knights and the
Bishops just dominated this is not
exactly the case this time around with
the move Rook C4 what black is saying is
I've got a very key outpost on the C4
Square as well as the E4 square and
that's my compensation for the two
Bishops we'll see if he made the right
judgment and tell us about the pairings
for Group B groupie looks great today as
well so many fun games are going on and
our key matchup for Group B is Samuel
lamassov and but suren two foreign
players very interesting to see them
here absolutely welcome welcome to you
both to St Louis so let's just jump into
their game because they have one of
those positions wow that's really very
very hard hard to judge essentially
white is putting all of his eggs if you
will in one basket he's got this past
pawn it can be a weakness and it can be
a lot of stress exactly it's on the
position that's it that's it is it an
asset or is it a liability and in this
case uh black also has a very active
Rook I just want to say on the second
ring as a kind of a compensation for the
fact that this Pawn is wedged in the
board uh wedged up the board the move C7
C6 is on Black's agenda to try to trade
off the C Pawn for the e-pawn if he
manages he's going to have an easy easy
draw these players are going to be
fighting so they're going to be fighting
hard what are they fighting for they are
fighting for a great price ones let's
start with this group a first place is
six thousand dollars second place is
four thousand and third places three
thousand dollars and then rest of the
tournament Players also get some prize
money for playing the tournament and
total price fund of the tournament is
twenty two thousand dollars thank you St
Louis chess club and tell us about the
group b prices Group B is the first
price four thousand dollars second prize
is two two and a half thousand dollars
third price is two thousand dollars and
then from the fourth to tens there are
going to be a prizes prizes as well and
total price fund is fourteen thousand
dollars I always like these tournaments
where everybody has a prize everybody is
happy right right I mean it sort of
feels uh quite professional thank you St
Louis chess club and again we're
starting a little bit late but let's
jump into the games because we have some
results first of all in um the group a
we have one draw already between Aram
and Rooney let's just quickly go through
it is it was a queen's game declined
with Bishop D4 and the players I tell
you uh begum they just know everything
right everything that's why it's not a
it's not a huge surprise for me RM is a
good friend of mine and then I know him
a bit they work on chess a lot I bet you
they do they're like opening soon
because they played it really felt to me
as if they had kind of blitzed this all
out now this is where I kind of stopped
right here because this last move Knight
C5 oh it contains this really nasty
threat of Knight takes E6 on the other
hand the reason I was stuck is because
this bishop on C6 it's almost like an
open invitation to moves like Queen G
Queen G5 and or Rook G4 and I thought
whoa you know like I I I paused so I was
a bit taken aback by the move Rook D6
which is just aimed at that neutralizing
that one thread but it kind of takes the
Rook away
um your your take here
I just wonder after Queen G5 G3 like
what can you do it's five square is like
blocked and then you don't have any
moves H4 is not the threat exactly if
you're behind development and Knight E6
or Bishop B6 is coming right but the
whole point of G Queen G5 and G3 was you
want to do that you know to make the
these nasty nasties you know and if you
it it felt like you know you just have
that moment the move Rook D6 felt a
little bit defensive and
here we go I mean to be honest maybe
ronak was just scared because Aram had
one hour 33 minutes after 95. wow would
you go to 25 I'm not sure you got you
making a very good point well what
happened is they just liquidated they
went as fast as they could into this
Rook ending this is insane why it only
spent uh 13 minutes to end the game
that was a draw let's go to the other
section because we have two draws in
that one our tournament leader Brett
well uh Brandon absolutely
well I actually I yes one of the leaders
yes we have Justin Wang and Brandon
Jacobson they just played each other in
the
us junior Championship so you might say
they know one another now is this move
d4
uh again as played in the World
Championship matches between nepo and
Magnus and it always struck me as a move
you could not make oh why would you
think so because first of all in the
opening what we understand from the
opening is we won our fair share of the
center we want to develop our pieces to
effective squares so for example a very
poor idea would be to play A5 and Rook
A7 we developed that Rook yeah but it's
not an effective Square so in the
opening we want to control the center we
want to develop our pieces to an
effective square and very importantly we
want the castle that's it so those are
our three goals now when you play the
move D5 D4
Pawn was already controlling the center
and D5 it was kind of hitting both C4
and E4 that's Point number one it
doesn't develop a piece and it doesn't
help us evacuate right now again not to
be critical because this is Theory this
is actually you know like this is a
championship you know but it was always
one of those things it's a No-No you you
shouldn't be allowed to get away with
this so and your take is hey it's okay
yeah okay fine castles uh C5 now here
white played E3 very sensible move by
the way you're attacking the center if I
play the move before I'm in a Banco
Gambit with an extra tempo right and I'm
white I played this position with before
uh yeah it was black pieces mainly oh
good and it's hard to like figure out
what to do with black if you don't know
what to do like but you should be very
prepared but you do know what to do so
tell me what do you do after before
and that's for sure huh okay C takes B4
A3 is one way of going and then you can
you just not take that
no I I happen to like E3 a lot and to be
honest E3 is more dangerous because at
some point you they need to play E5 as
well yeah and so basically it means that
you played E6 E5 another Tempo and D5 D4
right and which is which is kind of
weird and if you're not on time to
develop your pieces right not only your
D4 but E5 Pawn is under attack as well
exactly exactly
um I just want to tell you one uh quick
uh antidote story so I'm talking about
moving upon
moving upon but you don't you lose a
Tempo with that D5 D4
so there was a game that was played in
Yugoslavia and uh the players will go
nameless white opened up E4
so oh sorry I so this is the gong the
ringing of the bell and you know start
your clocks and then the Arbiter goes
around to make sure all the clocks are
are started
so the players have started the clocks
and players have moved and E4 Knight F6
E5 Knight G8 appears on the board yeah
the Arbiter comes around and looks at
the clocks and sees that the pawn is on
E5
and he says okay Gentlemen please stop
your jokes and he puts the pawn back on
e4
the white player slaps the hand of the
Arbiter he says the pawns on E5 and it's
my turn
he's like what so here it's sort of like
you play this move d5d4 but if the
Knight was on C3 and then you could buy
you know it makes sense right yeah it
makes it 10 but yeah so okay and you
were telling us that E5 is on Black's
agenda Bishop to G5 now here I have a
small problem
so the small problem I'm having is that
as white
it's it's actually pretty crucial okay
yeah should I play with A3
and A5 included that's a really really
important concept or should I just leave
that for the moment right like uh should
I just play for example Knight A3 and
just ask you the question like what are
you going to do I assume you you might
want a castle I don't know I mean right
yeah exactly Knight C2 and in this case
I've used the
A3 Square before I put a Pawn on it so
I'm just saying that the funny part
about this exact moment is
it has a huge relevance for what happens
next if I start a385 or if I go Knight
A3 and Knight C2 white chose to give up
his dark Square Bishop that's a very
interesting choice usually they really
try like A3 or night comes to C2 as a
way of being transitious yeah exactly
because right now in this position I've
given up a the bishop pair in order to
put my knight on e4 but it's not
established exactly and I can play five
at some point kick the night out exactly
so here we go b2b4 this is the the whole
follow-up of white strategy right is to
try to get this queen side expansion
take take take take
oh that was interesting I thought
wrongly obviously that White's intention
was to play Knight takes D4 he played
rugby now he did he wanted to that makes
sense he wanted to include this rugby
one exactly give me the tempo
Queen
and I don't know it is it is a weird
reputation of the game strange strange
moment too I feel like I would start
playing this position others right and
then when guys make a drop him and just
start the game
it's getting interested for example it
was white we would think oh B7 is a
weakness let's try to attack it exactly
exactly something I don't know whether
whether it be Knight C5 or whether it be
Knight C3 you'd be thinking in your mind
like hey
I'm gonna go here I'm going to go there
maybe on a good day I'll put my knight
on yeah it's a very strange uh draw to
be honest guys are very rational I guess
a very like objective about like
positions like this for example women
would like never make a draw they would
try to push it I guess many of them yeah
and for example uh Justin's view is he
started the tournament badly so he's
slowing down right like
is like it was
okay yeah every day for me
are you saying the women are more
aggressive yes chess players well
interesting that's actually a good point
we'll have to ask the club about that
but why aren't there women competitors
in the tournament I don't have the
answer I promise not to have the answer
either
Alexander Lindeman who like uh lost the
first game against Brandon he's with
white and they're playing a tarash
and again the same thing happened right
he lost the game and he's trying to just
like he doesn't want to make anything
worse like you start with a loss it's
bad starting with two losses do you
think it's a good strategy if you lose a
game then the next day you try to just
make a draw simplify
like without any risk right and then
slowly come back right so the idea was
that the Soviets taught us that after
draw after loss you always make a draw
stop the bleeding do it instantly yeah I
couldn't do that and I never did that I
have a huge problems with that too first
of all I was playing an American Swiss
tournaments American Swiss tournaments
you score loss too bad for you you
better win the rest of the games if you
want to win a prize so I was never
trained in this mentality of you know
like take it easy you know you always
just pedal to the metal every game and
you were always playing for a win and
that carried over through much of my
career much much later
probably I mean the candidates playing
in the candidates when I really come to
the realization that you have to score
every game by scoring every game that
means at least making yourself a point
yeah and you can win a lot of
tournaments by not losing which is kind
of confounding right because what but
yes but it depends on on the tournament
exactly right if you're playing open
tournaments try to score more if you're
playing close tournaments like that just
score a point exactly and uh the
candidates obviously are uh close
tournaments round robins and again my
training my upbringing had been the
American Swiss
100 players and if you don't score four
and a half out of five you're going to
go home yes sir I had no choice and for
a lot of people uh they always say Bobby
Fisher Bobby Fisher but he he hated
drawing he hated making draws dude look
at his his career he's he's playing in
these Swiss events now where he had to
win now we have Knight G5 Rook C8
Rook C1 H3
did you like that movie no I'm sorry 94.
absolutely I mean boy that I mean cute a
square on C5 too yeah
I'm totally agreed that's my my uh
opinion that's a gorgeous Outpost
94 95 begs to be played I'm really taken
aback by this move Knight F3 by Alex
maybe he he thought after 94 they're
still gonna play Knight P6 and he's not
on time for what because Knight C4 is
coming so he wanted to maybe play night
after an ip6 Knight E5 to control C4
Square as well so I'll toss in the move
B2 B3 precisely because what you just
said begum that you're ready to pounce
um can I take on e4 it's I know it
shouldn't be that great and then try
Rook D2
Rook D2 then you can check on C8 and
play Rolex him on right
the bishop looks pretty good here right
uh the problem is I see it is I just
wanted a little trouble here along the C
file like I'm good I am like you said
going to capture yeah none of that
doesn't happen but for me the move
Knight E4 I find
extremely compelling the move Knight F3
oh yeah you see here we go his ideal
probably he thought Knight on E5 is more
useful than C5 or E4
yeah interesting judgment call for me
I'm looking at this uh
you're like that's a Rottweiler this is
a second hold on it's attacking details
attacking E2 I'm not I'm not that happy
a camper here is a white uh maybe he
didn't uh
he didn't understand that after you
remove Knight E4 Knight p6p3 actually
black doesn't have much right yeah this
was a key Moment The Players after that
moment had passed
kind of just hosed the pieces off the
board uh by the way we're not forced to
capture you could play a move like
Bishop before and go into this type of
an ending which is similar to the game
except but the king is active if you
take Rook D2K F3 is also possible I
agree that's a that's a very uh not
inconsiderable Point
um maybe Rook a rook A2 is the problem
Rook A2 yeah maybe that's what he
thought something of this Nature by the
way these particular endings uh were
played by a grand master from Sweden his
name was Olf Anderson and he was this
unbelievably technically gifted Prairie
became the number three player in the
world both Anderson did and he loved
these Catalan type endings for those of
you looking to study and improve your
games look at the games of wolf Anderson
all right I should do the same yeah
exactly uh let's just jump while we're
here to our interview from yesterday
Chandra akshat came in I when I came
years and years ago to
um the St Louis chess club I had some
lessons well lessons is a strong world
where I had some
trainings with uh uh akshat and he was a
young I am at the time and he was
thinking going this Lou and and so on
and he's really improved a great deal
not because of our trainings but rather
he just improved because he works really
hard on his game today he's playing
against elshon Alshon has one of those
worst numbers that you can draw you go
to the drawing of lots and it's like
please dear Lord don't give me two
blacks in a row
maybe it's better but it depends
sometimes the tournaments are like that
your black is better than your white and
you will never know well I can tell you
this I think yeah in my career every
time I played in a round robin every
time
and I drew the number one number I won
the tournament oh really every time
usually number one is not good for me I
get the two whites I get black in the
last round by the lap time tournaments
more or less decided so that that so
really it feels like I'm playing with
two extra whites
oh I see yeah
last
for example yeah so anyway uh we get
this completely massively confused
position let's see what's going on Rook
C1 white has been very reluctant I
noticed to capture and I think that has
to do with some kind of a a hosing a
clearance I think if you take
immediately they can take and play C5
maybe C5 or E5 E5 which is really kind
of funny right
takes takes Stay Stay you it's like it's
like this complete vacuum cleaner yeah
probably that was his idea right okay
five and that was why akshot played the
move Rook ac1 kind of saying yeah and so
sort of saying well if we get to that
variation my Rook is going to be better
on C1 than on A1 let's continue Queen A8
uh
confused I wonder if it's night of some
Bishop says someone is an idea
Knight F7 King F7 Bishop F7 is
definitely
the idea because they're oops there's a
lot of Rook H5 is a move too like okay
try to push up G4 maybe 10
. wow
Zing Zang bing bing bang I mean you can
also protect the knights I was
I was far more cautious maybe with the
queen I was hoping maybe you want to
take it yeah I mean if we get a
variation where I end up taking the rook
and you know I kind of wanted my queen
over
intriguing uh unfortunately
he takes was and E5 I kind of they did
go directly and at the end of the day
akshot said give me the pawn yeah I'm a
pawn up what do you got I'm gonna go on
a good day I'm gonna go Queen D4
and bring my knight when you can win the
pawn why to calculate sacrifice uh good
point I mean I I guess you've been
reading my books
I read it all yeah Knight C5 and we've
caught up with the players uh your
immediate reaction do you like
the dynamic play that black has or do
you like the Palm I love the Palm here
yeah I don't think like and then even
like G3 F2 H3 pawns are so great
protecting the right thing right exactly
okay so slowly I'm taking over as long
as I don't play F4 like too soon too
soon I should be fine get caught in some
very very nasty okay so let me let me
you know
uh play my natural attacking brand of
Chess interesting what historians will
call heroic but we'll leave it to the
hood
to make that determination Queen G4 okay
G2 good move uh Bishop C5 thank you yes
sir
can I play F3 that's the question yeah I
think that that's that's really Knight
D3 I should be fine
you know what you know you played King
G2 oh let me just you know I mean you're
trying to trick me here
yes
no Queen G4 is a great mall after Rook
H5 maybe I have some potential for the
pawn again no no you absolutely do have
potential for it about oh okay but like
Pawn looks good Tom does look good but
how to protect my H2 Pawn that's a
question too King G2 is about maybe
you're walking into something it's a
queen G4 okay I should be more careful
and then play rookie one Rook E1 so I
shouldn't make any weaknesses I guess no
weaknesses for me like 93 now 93 no
maybe before even possible yeah
vis-a-vis the queen on the fourth rank
kind of means that you are in a pen not
necessarily that I want to play Rook D5
only just to recognize that the move
Rook D5 is available it's on it's on tap
I have seen many a Time
these kinds of sacrifices but is it
working I don't think it's working now
probably not because Knight G2 is a
great that's great yeah so for example
right I wonder Rick H2 is know
probably like worst case worst case I
can play Rook G1 and this is working
together because you spoke about that
kind of a defense light is a great place
right but even
um
even without sacrificing dispositions
uh these positions
uh
Queen H3 I'm wondering maybe I have
something maybe like I can create
something else sure I mean or maybe it's
too late here right to create something
uh even with my point was even with our
sacrifice sacrificing and the The Rook
or Bishop I think is still black can put
some pressure exactly but they should be
more precise than we are because it's
not our pieces so we're just like well
that's the beauty about this game
all right
when we got this we got this we got this
my move Bishop B6 by the way may have
been too encouraging maybe I should just
start yeah with uh the whole Rook H5
Queen H3 business because it does
require in this particular moment and
then Knight is hanging yeah that's a big
problem the desirable Queenie too well
you're just hanging the night so there
is that's the question I was asking how
am I protecting I I would guess you're
gonna go Queen C2 is it actually
possible to play group H5 immediately
instead of Queen G4
okay now we're really getting into it uh
Queen H3 immediately H5
I I just want to be more true like
C5 yeah and if you go Queen H3
queen of swan that's the problem if I
play Rook H5 then you're we're not
pinning the E4 Pawn actually and we are
just attacking yes so happens uh so
Queen G4 is very important yeah exactly
I'm getting uh we're not letting them
consolidate their position bingo
we'll leave that to brew again let's go
to our Marquee matchup game that's the
one of Simeon and when we left it we
just left it very few scant moves ago we
had H4 on the board H5 rookie eight Rook
C1 we're caught up with the players now
I'm a little bit confounded
is doing a great job I guess because why
didn't we play C6 because that was as we
came on the show we were saying that
that pawn on E6 is a great asset I
thought that's the idea of G6 because
creating a square for the king exactly
and you're just making it possible to
capture without worrying I truly can I
attack on C6 that's the question all
right let's have a look-see so I wanted
to take
hey and how are you taking on E6 I don't
I hate Queen
I hate being pissed no one likes it so
yeah this is the way I play chess so
Queen H6 right yeah okay so now uh
thanks to the nasty threat feels like
your Rook on city is too far away
maybe I can attack you yeah
I just I just have to be a little bit
careful here because I do have a counter
Spiel right like 73. Rook takes D3 check
F4 yeah or F4 yeah okay so I have to
rain in my horns nothing spectacular
yeah sweet H5
doesn't look sweet for you
it's one of those things
um
nothing broken through and I always love
seriously it's not a joke I really
always love these Rooks on the seventh
rank it always seemed to me that these
Rooks on the seventh rank were were
dangerous so for example let's just have
some fun my my queen is horrible but
attacking so far correct
so so far so E4 is not working right
Bishop Bishop E4 no not in not right now
but in the lines well let me show you
what you might have missed
very kind of yeah sir thank you maybe
Rook B1 I just wanna like be one I just
want to create some weakness first and
then Bishop E4 like if your attack was
the Knight check if you attack with the
queen check that kind of like situation
I want to create exactly so I mean in
view of this very very nasty uh
background check I I better go back yeah
I better be able to block the chat now
if I exchange a row suddenly my position
is horrible because of the queen right
correct
that's exactly right oh maybe I never
mind maybe I should play Rook B1
immediately results H5 so you don't have
Rook D2 and that's far more dangerous
and then my queen is fine too and by the
way
this for the audience is exactly the way
chess players think this is exactly
right we look at a position
we go down a certain pathway we come to
the conclusion wait a minute hold on if
I play H5 my queen could get trapped
jeez I don't like that and I know
because of that move Rook D2
I'm going to play Rook B1 right away and
now we go of course that makes perfect
sense
whites looking like
they're enjoying the position I don't
like it for for
for black which is probably why uh black
plate instead sorry
kg7 H5 rookie 8 and this is we're up to
date with the position it's interesting
to see the players it seems like but
surren is very calm while uh
but even though his position looks
better well I must say that I'm looking
you know it's pretty simple uh my
perspective is that the pawn the whole
game well maybe that's being a little
bit
hyperbolic but the pawn on E6 is such a
dominant feature of the game if that's
an asset
Black's in trouble if it's a liability
then it's okay but for the moment I'm
looking at that pawn on E6 and I think
black has a real real problem
unless he can capture it now it's going
to be a like a huge pin forever no
rookie one maybe well I'm just wondering
even that one yeah
this is not
the most Pleasant end game ever you know
it's not you can grab the pawn A7 after
it's also and as you said you know
another probably winning on the spot
it's one of those things and I hate this
I hate it please yes sir do you want me
to show that no there's a how do you say
this forever yeah yeah like the first
tournament today no it looks terrible so
in the current position with the Knight
hanging
how are we going to do this looks
terrible if we play C6
The Rook is hanging the night is yeah I
think but surround is in trouble and he
has only seven minutes
it looks terrible uh you know the engine
can say it's equal or something but like
you have seven minutes and your opponent
is like pressing pressing and then
putting real problems and try to solve
it yeah right with your clock too
exactly
um very famously Michael talls many of
his combinations were actually not sound
there was a way his opponent could have
escaped after two months of analysis and
then tal famously said well there's a
big difference between two minutes
you know like you solved the problem
it's more important than like
objectively not like the best move and
then it's situational right exactly when
and when you're playing you can feel
your opponent too yes yeah that's they
feel uncomfortable that's
that's the thing too by the way and I
really want to emphasize this uh for me
that Dynamic of over I I only played
over the portraits that was how we
played there was not even internet
that's how ancient I am so I'm at the
board
and I can feel my opponent's nervousness
the the legs
this
the pen writing you play online and you
lose all of that information none of
that is forthcoming from the other side
so we were doing these commentaries of
online tournaments and it was really
hard to understand yeah to get any of
that feedback that you want this
position looks really bad let's move on
back to the actual game for a moment
because he did play Queen G4 as you said
well let's see what happened actually oh
no never mind he played my move first
right and then came Queen F1 because
white is desperately worried about Queen
H3 Bishop B5 Knight back Queen G4
although it it looks similar to the
lines we're looking at yes sir I totally
like love your remote Queen G4 yeah like
Rook H5 I think we don't understand the
young people don't understand well
you're anxious to to immediately attack
right by the way uh
is down to a minute
for
30. to be honest Queen G4 would put so
much pressure because he doesn't know
like Rook H5 he knows what the opponent
wants right right and after Queen G4
instead he will he would be like how to
consolidate and he's in time trouble now
it's easier to play for him
when you have only one defensive moves
and like you usually find them and it's
easier to find exactly and the narrative
no I was just going to say you're
absolutely right and narrow path
where everything else loses exactly
you're fine the moves that keep you in
the game whereas conversely if you're on
a fair way like in golf that's you know
really Broad and you've got
four decent looking moves two really
good looking moves then it becomes and
tried to choose
what's going on here Luca looks busted
this oh God one of the uh we really
you learned this as you learn about
squares on the board okay you have a 64
Square Battlefield this is the
battlefield all of our mistakes all of
our brilliancies all of our blunders
occur on these squares but there are
certain squares that are terrible and
there are certain squares that are good
we have what we call Prime squares
one of the most beautiful outposts in
the world are Knights on D5 E5 F5 C5 C6
D6 E6 and F6 those are just
they love those they they are
right there they can show their full
potential correct that's exactly what it
is they can show their full potential so
now you have this secured Knight
and the combination of the queen and
Knight the different powers of the two
pieces combined really together super
well in this particular case Luca is
facing a mate in one and he's
desperately hopeful that he'll get some
Perpetual checks I don't see anything
for him I think after King D3 he's
disaster resigns unfortunately he cannot
play Bishop D6 because of Queen B6 all
the supporters are yeah
yes so that looks it's gonna be hurtful
for Luca exactly
did you see how the opening was he
played it was black pieces after
destroying him
hi okay and somehow it didn't go well
you know uh we were talking about uh the
worst things that can happen in chess
yeah
losing
yeah that's bad but losing with your
preparation that's like super bad but
then losing on both sides
like I mean how could it get worse
how could it get worse right you're
losing right I'm I'm upset for my
teammates okay let's go to the other
tournament and jump in because I guess
uh things are heating up with the time
control I'm looking at the game of uh
sassy
and John Burke
uh by the way John drew his game yeah
uh let me just catch up here but even
today he looks nice
he looks
counting the pie I am do you need help
yes can I use your fingers absolutely
our toes oh my God yeah he's having E6
and uh okay
uh I was about to say that you know I
played the French defense a lot yeah
this is
my French defenses I don't get these
kinds of videos
so after Bishop you too Bishop G2 and we
have a result between local Salvage and
Andrew hung as when we left it we
thought Luca was in Lucas Since
By the way uh you're right uh Bishop G2
but we are pawned down of course we are
hunting exactly Europe I just wanted to
tell you that in case right right the
bishop don't don't fall in love with the
bishop we might lose it type of thing
okay now here
the reason why I really liked your
Bishop G2 move as opposed to Bishop H3
and it's one of those things that you
just it becomes a kind of a second
nature to you you're always worried
about your team position that's one of
the five elements of Chess right it's
base Time Force Pawn structure King
position so your king position whose
King is more vulnerable when you have
your Pawn on F4 there's always a chance
that the diagonal right so I see the
move Bishop H3 and I think to myself
yeah can I play the move C5 yes or no I
mean you're probably going to take right
take take because one of the things you
don't want to do when I've got a bishop
okay so now you won your Pawn back and
you can congratulate yourself
except for one small detail
maybe maybe these ponds are a little bit
more I mean if I if I play Queen D5 A5
and then G5 is next it's just like I'm
attacking yeah that would be Overkill so
my first take is I think I like John's
position a little bit more now I can
also include the move Rook F6
potentially forcing you to play rookie
one where I might entertain ideas of
Queen E2 as well as C5 I think John the
bishop is so like so strong on D5 maybe
bishop G2 like had to be considered
absolutely I liked it more neutralizing
that Bishop now uh let's go to the game
of Nicholas and Ilya now for me
Ilya is one of those players that when
you see him playing in these opens he's
really dangerous like he wins a lot of
these open times that is true then you
see him playing in round robins and
something Mr Conservative it's like he
turns a switch on open tournaments he's
dynamic
in close tournaments he tends to be a
little bit uh too tight I think he is
more cautious exactly and let's see what
we've got some kind of a
English looking position I like Eli's
position because his King is his King
and then Knight is great with the ponds
with pawns
Knight is going to attack a lot of Pawns
here yeah it feels like Nicholas is on
the back foot I'll have to agree unless
there's some immediate way for white
probably Nico's gonna find some tricks
he's a very tricky big like player he
always search for some tricks to turn
the tables around yeah right I've played
many games yeah sometimes it's annoying
it's a trick Meister is the guy yes uh
for me uh forgetting about their
standings in the tournaments for just a
moment I would have said coming into
this event that these two players uh
Benjamin Bach I I know from Holland
uh I think it's a little bit overstated
to call Benjamin a prodigy but let's say
he was really really really good as a
teen we knew he was a great talent and
they was going to become a grand master
stop the question is would he become a
dominant player in Holland playing the
national championships win them play on
the Olympic teams and that kind of thing
as it turned out Anish Gary
surpassed him and honest Gary became the
dominant player
Benjamin's not bad
not bad at all but he would like to be
that type of a player as well here he's
up against Mishra same thing how
confusing is that Mishra is like
Benjamin box seven years ago yeah Mishra
very young Grandmaster very young
Grandmaster how far is he going to go is
he going to be a U.S Champion is he
going to dominate the Olympic teams is
he going to the candidates like Anish
Gary yeah that's a that's an interesting
question I was actually uh was around
like doing my job social media during
the Juniors so I had to interview people
right and then Misha was one of them and
we had a couple of like interesting
conversations and it feels like he's
very determined and he loves chess right
and he was so excited like last round
after his game he didn't go to his hotel
he was just watching like on my laptop
he was watching the games like yeah
excited very excited and nervous about
like winning the tournament as well
because for him this tournament win
means that qualifying for the U.S Champs
I think there we can see it was he's
capable of but for now I just know that
he works on just a lot and he wants to
beat all the records and he's like
really doing a lot of Chess and then
he's loving itself exactly well because
he's so successful but definitely
definitely determined now as we come
into the game I'm looking sorry I'm
counting pawns or something do you need
any help let me know
and it's like Benjamin he's the one with
the extra pawn and I think the one with
the best chances uh in this position so
for example if I take take I don't doubt
for a moment that uh the conversion is
not easy and the conversion is difficult
I think uh be money will escape today it
will escape well that's uh that's
jumping the script I wanted to say so
for example if I were black
one of the things I would like to do is
kind of you know
black has played G6 and nothing's wrong
with G6 except he's missing a dark
Square Bishop when you better protect
your squares right just better make sure
that you know and I like G5 ideas at
some point exactly and more more than
just the protecting the dark squared
Bishop I was really thinking well if my
knight is forced to retreat I Retreat to
D6 oink you spank my B6 Bond but if I
could Retreat to E5 I can keep the extra
Pawn so playing F6 covering my king
again I think the conversion is very
very difficult I don't think it's it's
ABCs of jazz but I do think that
Benjamin is for choice and Mishra will
be a little bit yeah I'm happy Marquee
matchup let's do it
not enough that was as we came on the
broadcast oh my God are you saved to
save the two Bishops somehow bad
Bishop C1 was a was an interesting idea
even though I still think it's not the
best maybe all right
um again the two Bishops
uh very very powerful advantage against
the two knights
unless the knights have powerful
outposts in this case as we came on the
air we were explaining that the The
Outpost C4 E4 really does give a great
compensation for the two Bishops as
we're seeing now having said that
still a lot of work for both players
here take take pause F3 trying to fight
we gave up upon but guess what we did
something kind of nice we we we we got
controlling the squares that's right and
we're at the same time we're kind of
giving this night a
awkward life like okay go ahead move
you're not going here you're not going
here and very likely you don't want to
do this I I mean I just think that again
The Rook is a little bit a little bit
hanging you always always always as an
amateur players most especially be very
sensitive to pins
uh those pins are nasty okay so after
Rook C1 I guess it's going to be Knight
A2 but uh let me pause ourselves to say
we have an interview and I am going to
take a break and you're going to have
Andrew holler now remember don't bite
okay I'll see you later all right
that's mine
congratulations
foreign
congrats on your win thank you
um it's felt like Luca repeated his game
from yesterday but with black pieces did
you prepare for this line
um so he played yeah he played this song
yesterday with the white pieces and uh
so I thought it was pretty interesting
that you repeat it I wasn't really
expecting this but um I remembered I had
some uh little idea a little try from
Analyze before and I was luckily I was
able to recall it so
um
that was pretty convenient uh he made an
improvement right he didn't play exactly
the same way his opponent did yesterday
yeah actually yesterday he played on
something Mainline he played this very
interesting trial with Rook E3 and we
should pay for and um but in this line
ends the driver wait you made an
improvement not him yeah well I just
went for one of the other lines I think
this um this whole lines probably draw
with the best place uh were you
surprised by the line or were you like
ready
I was like I was I wasn't surprised but
I wasn't like completely writing so I
was like in between
um I didn't expect this but I knew sort
of what to do so
um
yeah so he was bleaching out the most he
he had one hour 37 minutes do you think
he he missed Route 66 or he forgot his
line or it's just like after this
um I think uh he this move F5 he didn't
expect
um I think he told me that he was only
ready for like moved ip1 here
but after F5 he had to start thinking on
its own I think Rook C is correct Rook
C6 and but here Queen E7 you're supposed
to play yeah I was thinking of Queen E7
because the idea is after Rook C8 Bishop
C8 Queen A4 and the bishop is still
protected yeah that's correct and uh
yeah after cast is like important it was
Queen before yeah
uh could you do something else on Castle
I was thinking of F6 instead F6 I think
at least maybe I shouldn't take on
c86 here yeah
um
still do this at least so and he's fine
right yeah no I had
I knew more after Queen before here oh
line continues between E3 but
um I just thought it was a decent try
there's almost no risk for why in this
line so I might as well just see what he
knows I think he surprised me with this
Rook take C6 sacrificing the queen so I
knew this is at least better for wife I
wasn't sure how good and Alfred Laporte
wasn't so simple it was a very
interesting sacrifice because it feels
like your king is in the center and it's
hard to consolidate your position yeah
actually they're here there are a few
interesting ideas so first
if you trade first and play Rook F1 then
I think uh black can even try Rook C4
maybe tracking E7 and then it actually
looks quite good for black kids without
these pawns I don't have F6 to disrupt
the coordination
and um oh that's the reason why you
played that's why I play rookie phone
music but I also I spent a lot of time
here because I also saw like 92 maybe I
can play simply in this this also looks
quite good because the point is like you
cannot take because at least I have
check here in Queen B3 hitting both
pieces so
this is also a very decent option I
wasn't really sure what to choose I
chose Rook F1 because it looks quite
natural and because the idea being if
Bishop B2 and Rook F3 so let me
defending I'm turning Queen B4 and for
C5 Queen B6 of course
um could he exchange the uh on C3 Rooks
and the bishop was yeah somehow say this
happens but I think try to pressure is
totally lost because of the spawn I mean
there's no coordination on one to spawn
and then he's too late yeah okay it
looks I think it's winning but if you
find very interesting Bishop C5 which I
kind of like he also has this move Rook
C4 just interesting and Shopper checking
go to E8 looks very strange but it's not
so simple what to do with white here
um
can include Fe or I can play 92
immediately I was I think I was going to
play Knight two immediately and he could
maybe take on that five and okay I
thought
um like white should be winning somehow
um I wasn't sure exactly what I was
going to do here but with his bad
coordination should be good for what but
I actually like his move Bishop C5 is
actually
very complex here still because okay if
traffic should be seven and
so I tried I chose Queen G4 Queen F4 is
also an option because you cannot take
this yeah D5 haunting but here I was
afraid of uh rookie actually and he's
lining up on my king and
so it's a very complicated position what
was the crucial mistake from him
that's a good question I think after
Queen G4
I don't believe EF5 should work I think
he should play Bishop about fate in the
position the game still goes on white
I'm sure why it's definitely better but
but still like Bishop my face is a weird
move to Mech yeah Rook F3 and then the
cute black triplet like this I think
before cutting off my queen and then
just King soon okay so after uh
[Music]
after you go back a game for EF5 I think
here I could take here but I think King
D1 is also good I'm pretty sure this
should be winning um I didn't see clear
what for what he can do here I think it
was important that important that for
Rook g65 takes takes an hour key one
okay um and the point is like that's why
I took an H7 because here this pin
doesn't work because it's Greenwich
and then I think once the with the Rooks
traded it's um it should be lost yeah
this position already looks very bad
because D5 is falling yeah and the game
is after sc4 it was just over yeah he
made it easy for swimsuit four so how
are you feeling about this win it feels
like it was an easy game for you today
um
I want to call an easy win
um I respect my opponents a lot but uh
it's definitely nice to get a win to
start after a subpar game yesterday but
uh yeah I'll take it awesome congrats
and good luck with the tournament
so we are back to LA massage game
who just won uh
we stopped after H5 here
and black played
Knight A6 and
he played H6
King f8 which is already Queen after
Queen A7 it looks winning for him black
tried Queen D6
after Bishop six C6 Unfortunately they
cannot protect their position anymore
Rook F1 is a very good move after Rooker
7 Queen A8
it's good to have you here congrats on
your win can you please tell us about
the game a little bit yeah sure it was a
was an interesting game I chose an
opening that I don't normally play so D4
for D4 yes and has this reputation of
you know something where it's not easy
to find
um the win and even an advantage but the
positions are always unclear yeah I
played with black as well and it's like
and also Yasser was mentioning that how
complicated this positions can be
right right so so it felt like
black was doing good after the opening
as well well this is the this is forced
after Bishop C5 Bishop C5 a few moves
ago so after
like seven or something
yeah on move seven move seven Bishop
yeah C5 yeah so Bishop D7 is a more
conventional Choice instead of Bishop C5
sure
instead of 275 move seven
sorry my mouse is flying around
it's more conventional Insurance there
are lots of options for both white and
black in this line and uh it's not
really a fight for an advantage it's
more of a an attempt to get a
complicated position and just play so
that's what I was going for Bishop C5
leads the very first uh yeah line so
Bishop E3 Castle this has been played
many many times it's not like I haven't
come up with anything just yeah
so take Stakes Bishop C5
yeah it takes pretty much the position
after
Knight C3 Rook C2 Queen D4 is you know
one of the like almost fours you could
say yeah so a few moves yeah Queen D4
and I think Knight E6 is the move that
like E6 yeah Bishop E6 right yeah that
sort of that has been 33 most probably
yeah it could be 23 it's very complex
position again I wouldn't really want to
say no no 23 it has been played I'm not
revealing much by saying that you know
of course by saying the first light on
the engine Rook B2 and it's like a
complex position it's a mess
[Music]
um
yeah I thought that if you did that you
would have great chances for a draw it
seems pretty equal I also think Knight
E6 looks good and we saw how in the game
he was struggling he didn't have any
scores to put the Knight and eventually
it was lost basically right that's true
I would say that it does seem a little
counterintuitive at least to me so to me
Bishop E6 would seem more normal yeah
and I think if I didn't know the
computer evaluation I would say Okay
Bishop B6 is probably best here I
thought if I remembered correctly why it
was supposed to be better but yeah I
didn't know how so so kept explaining
yeah Rook fd1 F6
more
it feels like my Rook is kind of stuck
there and then now I'm Awakening my king
you're right you're right
um
on the other hand it's not easy to come
up with a good move so I was looking at
something like H6 a king h8 just to kind
of you know do something but I'm not
sure it's really it's hard to make moves
for both sides because I don't have a
clear plan but yeah he doesn't have a
clear plan too right because Knight
needs to be here to protect the kind of
like weird Rook here right exactly
exactly yeah I get that F6 is I mean
it's a very human move but I think I got
kind of lucky that uh there was this E6
thing
again I wasn't really like hoping for
any win I was just making just a playing
yeah and what do you think about this
Pawn it's like it can be a liability and
it can be a very like a very strong Pawn
right were you a little bit worried that
you might lose the phone yeah absolutely
I mean I didn't really calculate too
much because it's well there are too
many things to calculate but I saw that
I always had this bishop B3
Knight takes b38 xb3 yeah and at the
very least I'll make a draw because I'll
take on A7
so I was like okay if I'm losing the A6
spawn yeah
at least I'm making a draw I think if I
didn't have this resource I would be
twice as worried but okay I was fine at
the end
Rook d8 Queen E3
G6 yeah so H4 and after that
he played King j7 so we were trying to
figure out uh we thought with the other
idea his idea of playing G6 was to just
to create into some Square for the king
so he can play C6
um can he places it I think C6 is bad
because because of Bishop B3 Bishop B3
yeah so generally my idea is Bishop B3
everywhere that's why I play G6 because
the thread was Bishop B3 yeah the point
is Knight takes
let's say I take with the with the pawn
okay
and then it's very important to have
this move Rook to C6 right with black
and if black has Rook C6 I thought if I
attack you just yeah it's horrible and
if but again if black has Rook C6 let's
say at the end it takes text Rook C6 it
becomes not as clear so C6 exactly so
that's why I didn't play Bishop B3
myself but also why he didn't play C6
for some reason we were just looking at
Bishop C6 which was already like not
that easy too even if they take this
Pawn the king is too weak you're right
for example taking taking 96 Queen H6
Queen E6 Queen H6 lines good points well
I was I was focused on 360. yeah it
feels like after Bishop Beatrice they
just don't have much
uh yeah I think it's it's over I I
thought King G7 was good I also thought
about Rook D6 although I wasn't sure
yeah I mean I didn't have that much time
it doesn't show it right here but I have
about 20 minutes 420 moves so I couldn't
afford to spend too much time
cultivating so I kind of started playing
with my guts you know H4 H5 you know the
move that's somehow always the best H4
H5 yeah it feels very natural and then
right moves right because we can see
you're stuck again yeah I think I got a
little lucky
um about this rookie 8 22 because I
think if you played Rook V6 here or say
GTX H5 or Rook D6 it could be a little
more difficult for me yeah
um after Rook E8 I thought proxy one
just ended the game so that was uh that
was good yeah
I I I don't see any defense for why for
black here and then it was a it was a
very cute movie
yeah so I really liked it yeah like the
end of the game thank you yeah I didn't
see it at the beginning I was gonna play
it Bishop B3 let's say it's almost 27.
instead of Bishop C6 I was just gonna
play Bishop B3 and I'm like all right
whatever I'm upon up my king is better
he's not he's terrible I'm just gonna
play but then I saw this E7 move and I
thought okay I have to do this yeah yeah
you had to do that yeah it's very cute
congrats on your win it was a it was a
great start actually for you uh how are
you feeling to be in Saint Louis
actually I'm feeling amazing I've never
been here yeah it's your first time here
yeah yeah but it's I'm really enjoying
it and you know obviously if I started
zero out of two that could be a little
different but especially at two out of
two you know it's yeah
stuff to turn
around with you
so let's jump into aksha Chandra versus
al-shan
it feels like akshat still has time
trouble but he just made move 41 and he
had to give away the pawn unfortunately
it's so hard to play when you have huge
time travel here but he has a very
active broken Knight
and he's threatening to play Knight to
E5 and it seems like akshat is doing
totally fine here
good to be back guys
his interviews were wonderful and I
thought
Simeon especially really had good
control he knew yeah absolutely that E6
Pawn was a beautiful asset in the end he
didn't even hesitate he was like nah
if I lose it then I grab A7 so there's
no like Risk and apparently he's it's
his first time in Saint Louis right
he's enjoying yeah
when you play a tournament first time
minus was U.S Champs like women's U.S
Champs right yeah you just perform well
I remember yesterday
pretty good uh by the way no seriously
as I was sitting down and I was like oh
my
akshat was in a situation where we
thought he's kind of is suffering a
little bit but uh he's turned it around
he's the one now you mentioned 95 I was
coming in he's the one now looking at 95
and they have made time control too he
had he had huge time problems exactly
time trouble and people exactly he was
playing with seconds on and now he just
made move 41 which is like you know
right finally I made it and my position
is not losing then you start evaluating
actually it's spending time too a little
bit to calm down and understand what's
going on I guess in on the board well we
had always uh in my generation had this
idea that once you make that time
control that you just got up from the
board regardless of the position
took a while
you know like refresh refresh go to the
bathroom what cold water whatever come
back and then you know analyze and
making time control was a very big deal
uh back in the day they had these very
very long time controls sometimes you
really felt exhausted anyway jumping
into the game akshot has this very
attractive option one that I would
definitely be considering as white the
move Knight E5 uh you know in some ways
well thank you very much
he took it away sorry yes sir
you can give in return
um we had this wonderful conversation
yesterday about to suji and this idea
this Japanese word from the game of Go
which refers to domination yeah and the
idea of the interplay between the Knight
and the bishop funnily enough right now
this Knight is giving to suji domination
to the black Bishop on A3
like it would be a dream to go talk talk
talk talk talk please do nothing is
black just bring it down so you have a
great position I'll understand I don't
know why and how and then you just win
the bishop you think you sign the score
sheet in a way yeah if we had like
unlimited amount of mousse probably
would put the King on B3 and just win
the basically the piece and then the
game right exactly and uh only one
problem with King F1 could be Rook A4
exactly that's the one problem so from a
positional point of view the move Knight
E5 you're reluctant yes to play this
move because hey you work so hard to
ensnare the bishop now you're letting it
escape on the other hand 95 is
threatening to win all kinds of
delicious delectable pawns and so I find
myself attracted to that move from a
tactical point of view now here I really
like to make a very very very important
distinction when I say tactics to you
what I'm talking about is immediate
moves that win material yeah I play a
tactical variation I play tactical
sequence I play a combination when I
play strategically I am not talking
about tactics that I'm talking about the
placement of the pieces so a moment ago
I thought strategically it'd be
brilliant to bring my king to B3 here I
want to play tactically and play the
move 95. now but the problem is this you
know that I can take on B4 which is a
dream for me please take on B4 I want to
check
and I have two plus bones and I'm going
to stop them
are you sure you're 100
with my Rook on B7
uh you're not playing C5 you're going to
have to I'm just too slow right B4 C5 I
was thinking Rook C8 Knight G4 Buffet
then you can play Knight F6 Rook H7
checkmate
oh you're a very kind person I mean I'm
kind to my opponents not to myself
exactly exactly uh as I see it the move
Knight E5 the drawback of the move
Knight E5 is this Awkward Moment where
the rook and the Knight don't are not in
perfect harmony
it feels like akshard made a move rookie
yay
look at five Rook F5
Bishop I wonder can I take on G4 instead
of C6
okay now this one is a mess this one is
because a moment ago
I was about to say a moment ago with my
Rook on B7 I felt
here you're gonna have three I'm gonna
have two
and in those races you know who's gonna
win yeah the machines might go triple
zero should we calculate to live no
let's not do that let me just refresh my
board by the way and just get what move
he did keep with E5 which is so
surprised why are you taking away your
Square
wow I oh I while I find that move
confounding it he he has a point he does
yeah he wants to play E6 and then he's
like if you play the move Rook E8 to
prevent E6 well ha ha
[Music]
so even after that the point is is that
E6 threatens
uh to win the pawn so you have to move
your king and then akshat is saying you
know what I'm keeping my knight
domination
and I'm winning a pawn
[Music]
winning upon Barry that that that that's
that's good stuff it might be
interesting
can I play Rook a four yes it completely
legal I'll check the so far right so far
I am making at least some legal ones
that's good exactly take on before now
here though you're going to be in a
position
but my G4 Pawn is great too
but you're gonna be in a position where
I might be able to trade the E5 Pawn so
I'm gonna have one two three and you're
gonna have one two
but I'm gonna so I'm gonna make a bad
move for you I apologize in advance but
just to show you what I'm aspiring for
right oh this is lost yeah this must be
lost so my aspiration is precisely this
I'm gonna have two against one normally
two versus one in a rook ending is a
draw but the pawn is on B4 not on F7 I
think you can just wait uh until Pawn
comes to B3 and corrupt G4 maybe even
some instances right right uh but I'm
just saying that this is what akshot was
thinking about or calculated when he
plays E5 versus 95 because at first when
you see the move E5 you're like what
like did you just take away your primary
Square for the night and oh sorry uh I'm
going to refresh because I don't want to
go on he did play with V6 as we expect
and I don't see another Choice it's the
same way as you did well no the once per
broadcast we're always allowed to say
when they follow our analysis that the
players are very good
[Laughter]
wow they really are
uh yeah
I know
okay so here we have a an intriguing
moment I think you know what's my idea
please uh if you play Rook D4 I want to
play C5
that's the only idea that would be a
tragedy that would be a tragedy because
otherwise why this position looks really
good okay but here's another another
thing I could do I did it the dirty way
I went Rook takes H6 you know what
Bishop takes B4 and I jumped at the
possibility of going into a rook ending
here I can potentially keep a minor
piece that actually might be good like
we could imagine just for argument's
sake I don't care we could imagine a
position like this where it does not
only yeah right the night
will have a beautiful Square on E5 again
I'm just going to put some bad moves on
the board apologies in advance way in
advance apologies and you you can see
why I might want to keep the night
my world everything's looking good I
love the position me too I think
actually I think actually just gonna
Express this position if you don't mind
because we left it around here we
thought there was some play Maybe Queen
G4 instead of Rook H5 but Rook H5 can't
be terrible
could it what happened no I think look
for H5
G5 was not a pleasure
uh you know he was kind of he wanted to
be fast but he was slow
it's weird let me ask you a question
because time trouble affects all the
kinds of players differently
so first of all I love it when my
opponent's in time trouble I don't like
to be in trying trouble but do you find
and here's the question that when your
opponent's in time trouble sometimes you
get nervous you start looking at the
clock too and you you're like okay how
can I trick them yeah there are times
that's how I lost my games too exactly
it's just like you feel like oh I'm
gonna just make this move you know you
start playing shallow moves exactly it's
it's just so bad and then uh if you
don't know your opponent well especially
you feel like oh time travel they were
gonna make mistakes exactly which
generally a right statements like when
you're like in a Time trouble even sex
but for example there are great players
when they are in time travel they are
like strings doesn't change and then
they don't blunder anything precisely so
we had two great players in American
history Walter Sean Brown who won the US
Championship like six times we had
a giant of Chess in the 50s and 60s and
both of those players they were terrible
they were time trouble addicts and in
those days you would have it doesn't
matter a Time control of 50 moves in two
hours
and by move 20 they had two minutes on
the clock and these were analog clocks
with a flag raised and they would go
bang bang bang and they'd play 20 30
moves indicate in two minutes the other
player would have an hour and the other
player would get there
and they turned the tables in time
trouble they played better I think those
players are torture players Dirty Rotten
Scoundrels that should be illegal let's
see what happened well right here I can
tell you that that
this has turned terribly wrong and you
can see it immediately just visually
this Rook on the seventh rank I was kind
of intimating to you earlier how much I
prized a rook on the seventh rank this
night dominating this minor pieces it
looks like elshon should be losing and
oh again let me just let me refresh the
board because we do have I do not think
elshon is gonna play okay for
or H5 I'm I'm just trying to think how
okay and how he can still fight and then
okay for after Maybe
embarrassing oops so sorry he wanted to
go okay four okay four am I not more or
less getting the same position yeah
something yeah I just cannot yeah a
little difference fate wasn't the best
yeah where to put the king yeah uh
anyway some definite suffering I want to
go to the game of darouche for a moment
because that game our Marquee matchup in
the other
um
yeah group a uh was a very confusing two
Bishops
position after he sacrificed the pawn
yeah we left it right here and we
thought that the move Knight A2 whether
awkward or otherwise was necessary Rook
here and G4 okay
I'm sympathetic to this move because you
want to create an outpost but
on the other hand it kind of shows
understanding he knows some things like
in the substrate right
G4 but this is the Bishops it's kind of
scary to have pawns like push too
farther away exactly the drawback is if
this dark Square bishop ever finds
itself in a dominant position along the
long diagonal there are issues
uh King G7 here we go immediately right
right King G7 is an indication like
please take my Pawn
so that I can get counter play as well
like this Knight is really forlorn and
if we could go
if we could you know illegally play the
move Knight D1 and we'd be in business
at the moment I like this move it kind
of it shows restraint patience right
playing a great game so far it's
impressive no question
and now he gives up his Bishop but okay
uh counter play here with them look
after G4 F3 does it ignite is still
exactly exactly again kind of this
domination it's a very cute on structure
right uh and you immediately think to
yourself well how do I get
um
some better circuit yeah all right we'll
keep this up keep going here
fine okay here's a better circuit like
Knight D7 and
if you take he did he took and now
rookie six Rook takes B4 and now black
this is very interesting come on down
after like I after I play E6
apologies yes even better I'm tricking
you yeah you certainly are just a second
well in that case E6 might just win on
the spot I apologize
[Music]
I cannot take on F3 because King F2 and
then Rook G8 is a threat right right
this that's just a temporary not
allowing the old Arabian mate
no you can't even play Rook G8 or King
F6
that's right I wanted to say yeah maybe
you can play Rook G8 but then King F6 oh
you play King F6 immediately no no after
Rook B2 you played yes
B2 first uh if I play Rook G8 it
immediately
King F6 I can do night yet
all right that's that's pretty uh wild
right and there will be it's coming Rook
V8 King Knight F6 Rook B1
nice
okay well wait a minute
wait a minute I'm just saying just say
well in any case the point is darouche
is definitely the one in the driver's
seat yeah it is E6 seems very nice
but once again I have another idea 95
and whether you play E7
yeah that's what I wanted to tell you
but like yeah that's why I said even no
really good yeah I can play Bishop G2
yeah but now you can't let's say uh
now you can't
move the Rook
it's an easy draw I mean I can't believe
Rook G8 King is G5 and the best you can
do is trade the pawn the question is
that should I take on G5 or D5 most
probably G5
right you you you can you can do either
one you can go Rook G8 and take the G5
Pawn or just as you were about to say
and I think in in both cases I have a
pretty yeah and this is a good position
because maybe I don't have to play esab
on them
these six Knight E5 and immediately
Bishop G2 so maybe I have to exchange e
to F7 pawn and then keep D5 G5 Fitness
so you want to go E6 Knight E5 Bishop G2
and then you're saying that after takes
takes you just play three versus two
which is boy it just feels like it's
it's not going to be enough that's uh so
maybe I should be more
cautious about where to put my Bishop
maybe bishop E2 okay so Knight E5 Bishop
E2 takes takes so that in this case
maybe and King F2 and then maybe at some
point Rook end game can be win because
yes G5 is exactly four
skills I don't know uh one of the crazy
things about Chess is that yeah we have
this material advantage but
sometimes you can be a bishop and a pawn
up and then and it's still a draw when
the position is so reduced in material I
tend to think the games are much more
likely to be a draw than a win here you
know if this Pawn ever were to get
traded it's me to draw yeah that was my
feeling as well so okay we'll keep an
eye on that game I assassi versus John
Burke uh for me this is one of those
games uh at the risk of uh sounding like
an elder an ancient wise one or
something like that
Master versus student the professor
versus the student right as Sassy has
been in the top of chess for for a long
long while
John is trying to get his bones or in
his uh respect at the chessboard
he's doing a very good job because
obviously we're in a race where these
guys
than these guys and the good news for
John the Burke fans is that with the
move King H4 pardon me King C4
he's ready to support his pawns
conversely
well I don't know it's like an awkward
thing we have to position after H4 my my
knee-jer reaction is that John is for
Choice winning always a different kettle
of fish yeah your take but how do you
like it uh I think I
look Black's position
my Rooks to some I took where's exactly
now the problem is is the desirable Rook
H2
if I don't get my Rook uh like to to G2
or h10 and start pushing my pawns the
thing is that will suck okay you you
actually can be faster well okay so
let's start with the move King C4 which
as you've just prescribed can I releases
The Rook prepares to release the Rook
because we'll always be able to defend
the avoid please so King C4
okay and
um I don't mind
probably I should play H5 GTX hf5
most probably it doesn't work though uh
let's get my Rook around okay one was
probably right
okay one yes okay F6 will catch one F7
then A4
he must be winning
this looks really easy actually because
again you know my pawns are so Advanced
and you only got one it's going to take
you
eternity
never make it you'll never make it let
me uh refresh the board so I'm thinking
he played rookie too we're looking to
check first did John King have two I
think Kion F2 is better than E3 actually
now he doesn't have any ideas like
rookie one Rook F1 even after age five
it's a confounding check right unless
his idea was that he wanted to play B3
well well let's probably be three he's
thinking G4 King E4 it must
and uh but the H5 takes text King and 46
real good too I wouldn't play these
kinds of games I really would
uh anytime I have these connected past
pawns I think they're incredibly
dangerous yes you could play King and
maybe check and maybe I have some issues
okay which is going to repeat the most
and then just try to do something you
can't remember a bit too much sure
time on the clock let's just jump to
Mishra versus Benjamin and there we see
a very uh that by the way that that that
Saucy uh where he's bent over the board
whenever I've seen him and I from
decades ago he always had that intensity
that he was looking uh down and into the
position in his eyes too you can see
that yeah
I had this my first experience playing
vasili Yvonne Chuck it was hilarious
because uh I he had a great big
reputation of course when I I met him
for the first time when he shook hands
and the silly spent the entire you know
five hours rocking in his chair and he
was looking at the ceiling he never
looked at the board looked at the
ceiling okay made the move and went back
five hours into the game you know what I
was doing I was looking here
is there a monitor up there
who inspired by him right and then the
first time I played Boris gelfand Boris
girlfriend never looked at the board he
was looking at the square e0 it was
always they are one of my favorite
players so one guy the macro Cosmic the
other guy the micro Cosmic between the
two of them they had the whole Cosmos
covered
and you didn't have enough space I was
like I I felt I felt cramped I'm sorry
yes I know it was tough let's jump to
the game of Mishra and Benjamin because
when Benjamin Bach when we left the game
we really liked Benjamin's position we
weren't sure that he was going to
convert it but we thought that
interesting
we had this great game that sem young
just came in and explained how the E6
Pawn became this great asset that won
him the game and then
we said well is the E6 spawn an asset or
a liability it turned out to be a great
asset Benjamin's approach to this
position has been
that c Pawn is not an asset the moment I
play Rook C8 you play C7 I play E5 and
goodbye goodbye
wow nice A5
Rook B1 Rook C8 Bishop E3 in Benjamin it
all turned out I do not beautifully for
Benjamin yeah
yeah look at this move this is always a
nice move one of those moves like Bishop
E3 exchange did he have a choice choice
unfortunately right I mean Rook C6
is coming and as mentioned C7 E5 is a
showstopper
maybe then Bishop either
yeah and then maybe in that case but
okay but we are talking
big big big probably winning Advantage
for uh black here and then it's easier
to bring the king too right exactly it
looks good uh none of this happened
because he played Bishop E3 immediately
and Mishra is doing his darndest best
to stay in the game
and we have caught up with well we've
caught up with the players now after
this check
four Rooks endings are he's 10 minutes
behind on the clock but it feels like he
has some hope to save the game
[Music]
um
yeah yeah I hope dies the heart uh in
this position in this particular
position we have three problems for for
white
so it's really good sometimes you know
summing up your thoughts in in some
digestible manner that becomes very
understandable then you know what you
motivation is so what are the three
problems that I see for white first of
all you're Fonda terrible second
these double pawns are actually really
ugly they are bad sometimes you have
good double pawns not in this case you
have bad double bonds and then the next
and the last thing is your king is
actually vulnerable I mean in a worst
case scenario you can imagine that this
king gets checked from behind and they
these double pawns don't allow you to
escape conversely Black's King is
actually pretty safe so three three
problems you're upon down you've got
double pawns and your king is a little
bit vulnerable one of the things that
immediately says to me if I could draw
this game I could draw the game by
trading if I could go E5 trade the pawn
on F6 I get rid of a double Pawn so
when I know what my bad what's bad about
my position it's easy for me to say okay
how can I solve it now from Black's
point of view black
simple simple easy easy easy he just
wants to go put the Rook behind it the
pawn always very important and then uh
push the pawn also I do believe that if
he trades a pair of Rooks a single pair
of Rooks Rook C3
because of the double pawns I win the
game easily so also like
cannot really play rookie eight after
kf72 because Rook B4 and as you said
double pawns right and then a rook C4 is
coming another rook and rookie four
right and I'm protecting E7 Pawn a four
Pawn I don't have any weaknesses and two
pounds up
finish finished
so again as in summation if I'm in black
shoes if I'm in Vegas I'm thinking a
single trade of Rooks and I got the game
under wraps so if I play the move Rook
A8 for me
this is a completely lost ending my next
move regardless of whether you play Rook
A3 or not is to play Rook A8 King Rook
behind the pawn and I win so from
nisha's point of view he can't afford to
trade Rook so he's going to be playing
you love chasing the pieces right yeah
here we go yeah and you know we could
get a position where
we are bouncing around with the Rooks a
little bit here here let's see uh let me
just go back pardon me I want to go to
the game position apart apologies I just
yeah
um
it seems to me that I would like
actually to go king after seven so again
I'm dreaming about this and I think more
or less you're obliged to play Rook A8
then look before yeah Rook h8
H5 or kg7 I don't think disturbs the
overall pattern and then we're getting
uh to the move Rook before and this is
again why these double pawns are really
ugly right Rook here and if only my
phone Pawn was instead on F4 then it
would be a draw well the chances of draw
go through at least I I wouldn't have a
weakness and then I could attack your
weakness exactly so we think that uh
Benjamin is really enjoying the proceeds
once again let's go to darush and
[Music]
um
King F2 so he's preparing in six
but he's being smarter than me
very very very difficult I that's very
very hard to imagine that he could be
smarter can you imagine no no not at all
so sad uh again I think from uh prana's
point of view any pawn trades are to be
embraced so I would really be looking at
the move d4 here if you avoid the pawn
trade then yeah at some time this is a
lovely position yeah well I'm a pawn
down and I'm suffering but yeah I get
benite yeah then I can save the game and
then pawns are fixed so it's easier for
Knight to jump around exactly and the
fixed on
light squares yeah why did why did white
box to do that that's what king F2 feels
like a right move you're bringing all of
your pieces you're improving but the
problem is I have about the timing right
yeah yeah if I put as you said Knight f8
Knight E6 and then D4 just exchange one
pair of I've got a great blocking yeah
yeah maybe indeed our moment
well sometimes these guys aren't as good
as I know they're just too good
sometimes
that's terrible okay and uh
we remind everybody where we are in
terms of results in group a group b
apologies group so uh Justin versus
Brendan they made a draw Alexander
Linderman versus Armand ended in a troll
as well and Andrew Hong won his game
against Luca buddhistaviewicz while
while Simeon lamasov won his game
against batsuran and we have one more
gamer mind reminding in the B section
which is Akshay Chandra versus elshon
and uh wow it seems like elshon really
did play H5 then rookie four yeah so
when we left it I had that yeah I had a
feeling that he would play this Rook A4
oop
no I have to you have to update it yeah
yeah that was our analysis apologies
yeah but they did kind of go into our
rookie here Rook here oh
Bishop takes maybe that one was on our
analysis and I was saying I grabbed the
Rook ending thinking that the Rook
ending is winning but then kind of like
backtracked and said well maybe the
night is actually a superior minor piece
to the bishop because we can imagine
variations where the Knight could take a
commanding Outpost
it must be crushing
it feels very very very good yeah
I think actually it's gonna grab this
round
looks really really good for
back so far yes
even as you mentioned before E6 now
and I like this too I I in fact I just
simply like everything about uh
anyways exactly and The Rook is going to
be
you know there are certain times when
you can you know take pride yeah so now
I understand why you like Roots
this one
gets uh you know my top agent of the day
award The Rook is doing a great great
job uh preventing the pawn from running
as well as being an aggressor so ax
shot's looking really good by the way
just to remind everybody but should
akshot win this game he will score to
how to start so far the quality of his
games are great too exactly yeah very
impressive yeah right indeed and St
Louis will rejoice as akshot is actually
a local here in St Louis so yay
I know who you're rooting for well again
I have this history uh with uh actually
in a good history uh by the way
we were just here and I was kind of
dumping the table for King C4 at once
keeping the Rook again on the second
rank in this case not the seventh but
the second and uh you know ready to
put the Rook behind upon the check was a
little bit confounding because that made
us think that John was aspiring to play
B3 no he just said okay I Drive Your
King a little bit backwards you've
declared that you're hanging around the
king side now what are you going to do I
don't think there's a choice I'm gonna
play G4 but yeah so how do you feel
about Rook A3 move we were we were
trying to activate our Rook from A2 but
we put it on A3 which yeah feels like
even more passive but I I'm not I'm not
I'm not too critical I'm not too
critical I think that it's okay uh
uh because it's one of those moves as
you described you can take it back and
you can go look back to A2 check and
you're likely to repeat the position in
which case no harm no foul and you've
gained a minute on the clock in this
particular case he I think in John's
favor he does have a point if you play
G4 and I think you have to play with G4
you could activate the Rook right away
whereas from the A2 well that's not true
from the A2 Square you could activate it
as well H2 yeah but king would be on E3
so his idea is that King on F2 is more
passive than E3 and then after Rook H2
for example king would protect F4 Pawn
while here King won't protect F4 pawn
and basically if he takes on H4 for
example somehow Rook F4 is a check
because King on F2 and if we were here
and the King was two is in the game okay
so maybe it's a difference in some lines
that he calculated because it's hard to
predict or like hard to guess what kind
of lines he calculated here there's so
many of them no question and I'm just
going to repeat the you know update
pardon me repeat update so go ahead
let's have a look see we're going to
find ourselves in a race whether we like
it or not I think well I'm certain that
John is faster in the race after all his
pawns are more advanced but G4 what's my
idea very simply I want to play H5 so
for example Rook here I want to play H5
and most importantly I need to have
connected past pawns I cannot afford to
play something like F5 and have a lone
Runner whereas in this case I I mean I
kind of feel like
it is on time
okay let's have a look-see because these
things these games are these positions
pardon me are really sharp so let's say
I play here
you play here right no choice
you play here I go and now I don't I
cannot play F6 because it's
F6 check as well so maybe Keyon F2 is
indeed well just a second we do have G7
right yeah so I have to apply
F6
push okay I think we have to play Rook
A7
this is what I meant when I said it's a
total mess right push
push but now
if you take on G sub and then Rook A4
and f8
and a very very important switch and Zoo
it is 25 f8 you take on A4 well take on
Gisella but in this case I'm desperate
to try to make a draw with black and we
thought that John as he entered this
ending is superior so
um this type of analysis tells us that
the very straightforward isn't isn't uh
enough and after G4
let's try another analysis for John
let's try the move A4
so H5 takes G5 H4 in this case I feel
like I've saved a tempo right haven't I
saved a tempo
you did
and here okay and Rook G7 is on Tab but
here I I think so that uh and again and
again uh we are not using the chess
engines and one of the reasons and the
most important reason why I don't like
to use the chess engine during the
broadcast is because you can look at the
chess engine and you can say oh yeah
yeah you should play this move yeah as
you missed you missed this move the
chess engine says it's a straw I'm
struggling but when you hear my thought
processes this is why I'm struggling
that's exactly what these guys are doing
they're going through the same uh
discussions with themselves or having
this internal discussion ooh Rook H3 I
lose a Tempo oh I got it I'll play A4 so
oftentimes a lot of our analysis leads
to variations that do not work and
that's very important because that will
teach us what does it work so I always
like this say look I made every mistake
at least once usually twice Thrice Force
One so be sure that I'm into mistakes
exactly right so you know here a lot of
the things that I consider at a chess
game
I end up throwing out and saying ravish
be serious yes sir that doesn't work
that had no chance of working why why
were you analyzing because it might lead
me to the right idea yeah and that's
that's what we're talking about here
with John Burke we think that he is
better probably even winning but he has
to be precise and we think that the move
G4
uh A4 pardon me that Arrow really sucked
uh should lead to a win for him now G4
is not the only move because he needs to
consider rooksy sub on check too right
how much would it help and then I don't
think it helps a lot one of the things
you might do see after G4 and then your
Rook is not going to H3 or G3 anymore if
you go to the third well but be careful
because this Rook was uh how do you say
keeping a a very important eye on my
Pawn right G2 Rook here yeah yeah and
then I'm not on time
well if you play Rook B3
what if you play Rook V3 I can take G7
B1 j8 and then hope for a drop oh I hope
for a draw that's exactly right uh but I
was going to play h
yeah that's it that's the problem
and now my very next move is cleaning
and your king can't support the pawn so
we think John is doing really good uh we
think that um
Mishra is likely to lose uh
and yeah this looks like a really
beautiful tournament for me he's
bleeding yeah it's a very bad Engineers
he didn't lose any no and he's the only
player who didn't right
he was unblemished and in this event he
started with a loss and it looks like
he's going to go down to another loss uh
darush
how about that interesting we did not
see the move we expected the move we
expected quite simply D4 because we I
think most especially it was in his oh
he's TR he's trying to reproduce like it
would be two King G3 Rook B1 the idea is
if you play King F2 I will make a draw
easy with a Check Yes ah
so where to put the bishop I don't see
any squares that cannot be attacked
Bishop G2 no uh your shop was very
passive maybe it would be three
Rook B3 what do I have E6
I mean yeah Knight F6
um
takes on F7 I mean again you're you're
very very close to making a draw but
still I have to work on it yeah
I'm not giving it away I'm not giving
you a draw you still have to prove it so
to speak well keep an eye on that one
and uh pardon me I wanted to see again
we really really like what Benjamin is
doing is looking good we think John is
looking very good and let me just check
out I'm used to hitting control tab by
the way don't ask me why from the
previous oh this is the this is the one
we talked about Rook ending that I
really wanted I just know that this is
an easy win for white because the point
is is what white and it's almost
impossible black cannot stop white From
Bling yeah Rook B7
H3 and then it's two connected past
bonds versus the single pass Bond and
the two connections can I get greedy and
try to win G4 Panda not necessary but
tell me how you want to get greedy I I
admire you're you with the way you're
going but how are you moving how are you
going to get how do you get kind enough
to move your
Tree on
ah I will be very happy to do that for
you so even though you're holding the
pawn so I have to exchange your account
you will you will be delighted with my
um my play so there you go there you go
there you go so you want to say that
rather than when two connected pass
pawns you want to win with three sure
okay
no it doesn't work yes sir
I used your kindness
take the pawn everybody listen if you
don't know what to do you can just cause
can I get the phone right I I gifted I I
had this trainer from Bulgaria
International Master Nikolai menev a
really blessed man I I really enjoyed
Nikolai a lot and he came late in life
to Seattle
with his wife Elena and he had some
expressions from Bulgaria that
translated and the way he pronounced
certain words was a treasure and one of
them was not give
exactly right gift me the Checkmate
thank you very much actually
and let's just take a look at the
standings once again uh in the two
sections do the Honors group a so far
ilionic has one point or ramacapian and
then ramnak and Nichols theater as well
but they ended their game stereo versus
Praveen they are still playing as well
as Benjamin Bach and John abhimanyu
Mishra and John Burke with Krishnan
sasikuran is on the way as well exactly
uh as we get ready to close up the show
I'll just throw one other tantrum at you
here
and again whenever you're in races uh
one of the things with these Rook
endings is
I'm not joking it's incredibly tricky
these Rook endings are incredible from
the game of Saucy versus John you know
we've been looking we found a few tricks
but let me just kind of throw one of the
things that we haven't looked at at you
so sassy is thinking about uh he's
thinking about G4 he's thinking about
Rook here he's thinking about Rook C7
check and he may also be contemplating
this F5 so what happened suddenly takes
H5
[Music]
now if you play okay too I can play with
King G1 right letting you right I'm not
letting you get behind so I really don't
like rookie so you you start to think
okay and then you go oh I've got this
I've got this idea that is true four F4
right great idea
G4 4 G4
you're still catching my my Pawns
I'm not sure and you Rook H3 absolutely
right
G4 and then we're happy then we're happy
so H5 B3 wait wait I can take on H6
well then I have to be really no no it
doesn't work then I it does I don't know
I feel like I don't like it you're okay
true but it's working it's working and
so far and I talked to lavono ronian
about that too by the way and he said
yeah sir one of the strangest things
about Chess and his study and Analysis
of jazz
is he has what he calls natural moves
these moves feel natural you you develop
your queen you put it in the middle of
the board it attacks here attacks there
and then you're sitting there at the
board and you go oh my God this really
ugly move
ugly move Queen on D4 which was really
really really really really really
powerful goes all the way back to A1
it covers the first rank it protects A7
and the Ugly move wins
and he said to me he said I am looking
for the effective winning move and I
don't care if it's natural and I don't
care if it's ugly
and he's right you know Rook A3 may not
be the most but if it works it works
yeah also there they have like seven
minutes versus nine minutes so it's
gonna be a hard game and then Rook end
games are very complicated as we said
most of them can make mistakes which are
crucial one last look is our Marquee
matchup and we're going to wrap it up
and call it the day as we have a a
couple of moves we one of the things
that darus position really was lacking
I want to put it that way was the bishop
was on F1 it was kind of passive Frankly
Speaking
wow looky looky looky the bishop the
wings of this bishop have just fabulous
it went from being a rather passive
spectator to a bishop that's actually uh
really powerful and after King F2 we
have a position where I think darush
is happy he's improved his position a
lot uh King here
I must assume he wants to go to D4 was
the king well I really don't like this
idea of
like for black yeah I I like your idea
D4 and I become six you trade it off a
blockade absolutely what I'm saying is a
very active Rook
now and quite suddenly a very active
bishop and any Rook B2 check suddenly a
very active King I would know me gusta I
am not don't sign me up for this one I'm
seeing a passive King active active but
I'm a pawn down by the way
so it looks like darush I would say has
excellent chances of winning this game I
have a feeling he totally forgot about
D4 Square
yeah sometimes yeah I have a feeling he
he thought oh King cannot go far and I
totally forget about it what we're going
to call it the day we do think that uh
oh yeah and Benjamin has achieved the
the maximum I want to say he did win his
way to win the game yeah
I suspect that the move H5 gh5 G5 and
mortgage four is crushing absolutely I
suspect that's on his agenda yes sir I
like your Technique you you are very
good with winning positions uh I used to
pride myself until I saw the guys of
today
in particular uh it's shocking me when
I'm watching
Hikaru Nakamura and most especially
Magnus played Blitz Games that after the
games they say it's 98 there's an
accuracy I'm like this is a Blitz game
and they played it with Incredible
accuracy I don't think in my classical
games I had the kind of accuracy that
they have compare yourself to them why
not
yeah
right I mean I I played with Gary
Kasparov and Anatoly karpov and we used
to have these adjournments and then our
accuracy was much improved but today's
players and their accuracy is remarkable
I think even if you like
okay and let's go
big changes happened here what what oh
my I told you probably he's talking in
thinking of Booksy savan why would you
put your King on A4 that's a head
scratcher I think I had a feeling that
he's going wrong direction after Rook A3
that is really a headshot it's just a
passive move too
I'm not uh I'm not a fan I'm not a fan
but bacon as we close the show I wanted
to say thank you so much once again that
was really really enjoyable we're going
to be doing this uh absolutely for the
next before we end the show Let's uh
it's the descendants of the bigger as
well all right here we go is
so far crushing and he has the full
friend in Jacobson is after him with one
and a half points and Andrew Hong is
also with one and a half points after
two rounds where Armand made two trolls
and he has one points akshat is playing
yes
should win to jump up and join samian at
the top yeah Alex Slenderman made a draw
today and has a half point you stop the
bleeding elshon is playing with akshat
as well and we are still waiting on the
result and but Suman lost his game today
against lamassov and Justin Wong made a
draw he also kind of stopped the
bleeding right and he has the hover
point and woke up with the sandwich
unfortunately lost two of his games and
then the standings uh in the a group
it's still to be determined as three
games in progress thank you so much for
joining us remind your friends where
you're hanging out uh join begum and
myself for tomorrow we start all of our
broadcasts at four Central Europe I was
about to say Central European Time
Central can you believe that I can't
believe I was about to say that you know
look at your Greenwich Mean Time watch
and call it for St Louis time
you still didn't figure out
Central Time thank you so much and we'll
see you tomorrow see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited